heavenly father again it's been it's
been a long day as we come towards the
end of the afternoon
father I just pray that you would give
us a heightened sense of alertness and
awareness
Lord we've been sitting here the
students have been sitting for a long
time and I just pray that you would help
them to grasp uh this subject to
understand clearly father keep them from
the fatigue that would hinder them from
understanding and from getting the full
import of what we're talking about and I
just pray now Lord for the blessing of
your Holy Spirit the spirit who inspired
the prophets may he now Inspire us we
ask in Jesus name amen
you need to talk to uh
talk to David Sherwood or talk to Pastor
ashrick or somebody about getting a
louder fan if you can you can get
something Louder Than This sounds like a
jet airplane taking off instead of a
twin prop
anyway that thing's loud
from up here you can all hear me okay
can you
huh
no i i people are the circulation's fine
I just want to make sure you can hear
okay I've got the okay from the back all
right
had several questions during the break
so I'm just going to spell this out for
you
it's a little better
um
you know somebody asked me to well I
don't know if I should say that I'll
just put it this way I already said
there clearly are different viewpoints
on inspiration the Viewpoint of The
Seventh-Day Adventist Church on
inspiration is the one I've just given
you okay there that that we're there
were there errors in the original there
very well could have been
but they were not such errors as to
change in any way the Eternal truths of
the scripture okay now if you want to
say well Pastor Howard you know I
personally believe that that discrepancy
with Jeremiah and Zechariah was a
copyist error that's fine I won't take
issue with you
neither will I take a position that the
scripture is any less inspired because I
see these discrepancies
but what I want to get across to you is
that when we understand
true Bible inspiration which is thought
inspiration
it explains a lot of the potential of
how some of these things could come in
God used Humanity to write the
scriptures and I think in times I think
God showcases Humanity in the scriptures
you know we say well I don't know if
there's any possible possibility of
errors in the original manuscripts but
look at the look at the very characters
of the Bible
God allowed problems in the characters
of the people in the Bible what's that
tell us that tells us that they were men
like us who struggle with things like us
there are women like you now I can't say
like us who struggle with the things
that you women struggle with right they
were real people they had the same
struggles so God spoke through humanity
and we see this and God uses these human
examples somebody may say to me well
Pastor Howard
I believe that God preserved the
original manuscript the original
autographs from error
why didn't he preserve everything else
from here
could he have
yes or no absolutely
I believe that God is showcasing that
even in frail with frail Humanity God is
able to get across the Eternal truths of
the Gospel okay
now
as I said to some during the break and
before the break I maintain that all
scripture
is given by inspiration of God
even when I find a discrepancy and like
I said copy a stare maybe or maybe
Matthew like I've done in a sermon
sometimes says you know
I went to Mission College of evangelism
when it was in Oregon Black Hills
and Pastor Torres told the story of a
time that he gave an appeal
at the end of his sermon and he says he
was calling people forward he said now
with every
head closed in every eye bowed
and he made his appeal and he said I did
it again
with every head closed and every eyebrow
and he said I did that three times and
never caught it
did he know what he meant
yeah and the people knew what he meant
and it didn't change the fact that
people still came forward and gave their
hearts to Christ okay
and I think in much the same way I I
don't have a problem with saying that
Matthew said
you know just like Jeremiah said oh you
know later on he's probably saying I
meant to say
who knows but it doesn't change the the
fact that there was a prophecy that said
that Christ would be sold for 30 pieces
of silver that came true that was
fulfilled okay and that doesn't like I
said that doesn't shake my faith it may
shake your face but I'm going to tell
you my concern is
I think down the road you're going to be
in for some challenges
if you hold to uh but let me put it this
way
if indeed
the Bible was inspired in a particular
way
for you and I to understand a different
mode of inspiration than God actually
employed
has real potential to derail us down the
road do you understand that and I'll
leave it at that now you've got a
section
Herbert Douglas talks about it in his
book touches on this a little bit and he
isn't real dogmatic about which way you
know with the errors and other things I
just want you to know that there are
different viewpoints and you're not
apostate
neither do you throw away the authority
of scripture if you want to say well you
know it's possible that Matthew
misquoted
it's fully in the realm of of plenary
inspiration
do you follow that
okay
let's look at Ellen White's writings and
here's where to me this makes you know
kind of makes even more sense as to
taking that Viewpoint look at what it
says here in the review and Herald of
August 18 1874 letter A
Satan flattered our first parents that
eating of the fruit of the what
the what
Satan flattered our first parents that
the eating of the fruit of the Tree of
Life which God had what
a what
is that what God forbade no no now watch
keep on reading
would bring them great good and would
ensure them against death the very
opposite of the truth which God had
declared to them but of the tree of what
knowledge of what
good and evil did she know what she was
talking about yes but evidently brothers
and sisters and we the thing is you
could say well copy a stare sorry we
have manuscripts in Ellen by its own
writing
and there it is
so what do we do with it
now if you want to hold
position there are no no errors in the
original autographs you've got a problem
right now because you've got some
different mode of inspiration that's
going on with the spirit of Prophecy
than you have with the Bible Prophets
and the view that I take and the view
that The Seventh-Day Adventist Church
takes I have no problem with that no
issue at all doesn't doesn't affect your
inspiration at all
she put down the wrong words did we know
what she meant sure
did this derail anybody
I'm I'm positive that it didn't if it
would have God would not have allowed it
in there I do think God preserves his
writing from uh errors that would cause
a person to lose their soul do you
follow me on that let's look at another
one look at letter b
the beautiful Temple that for more than
four centuries in accordance with
Usher's chronology that's not uh
well that's just a side note had crowned
The Summit
this is Alan White's words the beautiful
Temple that for more than four centuries
the in accordance with us chronology is
not her words that's just to give you an
understanding of
that that she that she wasn't uh that
she it wasn't she wasn't completely off
the wall I'll touch on a minute had
crowned the summit of Mount Zion was not
spared by the Chaldeans that's Prophet
kingdoms page 458. but archeology this
is not her now but archeology has since
proven that it lasted only 384 years
okay so what do we make of that Ellen
White says for more than four centuries
384 years isn't more than four centuries
but understand something
let's take our video again
you God gives you a view
of this video okay
you see this is this man David Gates
and you're going to communicate now to
people about his ministry you know what
you saw in the video now let's just say
you want to inform people about David
Gates what might you do as a prophet
did the video give you all the details
about David Gates the vision may not
have either what do you do as a prophet
if you want to convey some more
information
you may just take some common
information you say you know I had a
vision of David Gates I'm going to look
up you know this is this brother over
here you may get information from
somewhere to fill in details
okay
are you following me on this
Ellen White
claimed herself
that she was not a historian there were
people that they read uh great
controversy they said well wait this
historical date has this we've found
sense that this has changed she's like
hey I'm not a historian I'm conveying
what God showed me and I used the common
sources of the day as far as the dates
of History went
thought inspiration
in the same way it was a common
understanding in Ellen White's day from
Usher's chronology that that Temple was
over four centuries old
but recent archaeological finds after
she wrote that said no it wasn't quite
that old
you follow that there's a discrepancy
there but when you understand how
inspiration works it's really not an
issue
letter C when Ellen White joined her
husband at Walling Mills Colorado she
dated the event as Monday August 8 1878.
that's in testimonies volume 4 Page 297.
however Monday fell on what
the fifth that week and not the eight oh
she must be a false prophet right
this is what the critic incidentally who
do you think found out that that date
was on a Monday or that date rather that
uh
where was I that that date was on the
fifth and not the eighth who do you
think found that out
some critic
some critic looked it up and said well
I'm going to find out about this
now we went through the tests of a
prophet did she pass yes or no
does this change it
because she put the wrong day
Millions won to Christ but oops look she
put Monday when it was supposed to be
Wednesday now she put the fifth one it
should have been the eighth
now I tell you if that's your view of
inspiration you're going to have
problems in the scripture and in the
spirit of Prophecy
it's just not the way the Bible was
inspired
look at the next one in 1864
Ellen White stated quote the beautiful
Eve was beguiled by the serpent to eat
of the fruit of the only tree of which
God had forbid in them to eat or even
what
touch it lest they die spiritual
prophecy Vol 4 Page 120. you'll find
these things on the websites all over
the place and they'll bring these things
up yet in 1874 she wrote quote in Eve's
controversy with a serpent she added the
claws neither shall ye touch it lest ye
die
now what do we do with that
what do you do with something like that
I think that's very simple
once again don't forget how thought
inspiration works
God shows Ellen White and we're going to
talk about this a little bit more Ellen
White as she went through how many of
you have read early writings
how big is early writings
okay in the second half of early
writings you have a book called
spiritual gifts volume one
okay
that's half of the book it's about this
thick
you know what that spiritual gifts
volume one became
the conflict of the ages series
right
you put those five volumes together
you've got a set like this and yet it
started out with this many pages why
because over the course of time what did
Jesus tell his disciples there's many
things I'd show you right now but you
can't bear them
over the course of Ellen White's
Ministry God revealed more and he
revealed more and he revealed more and
as she got more light she expanded the
volume
when she received this vision
where she wrote for Spirit of Prophecy
Vol 4 page 120
I'm guessing just from what I'm reading
here that as she saw what had taken
place Adam and Eve Etc the whole
situation the fall of Man evidently she
was not given the detail that she got in
reviewing Herald in 1874. she knew that
man fell and where are you going to go
for the details well you go to the
scripture you read the story what does
the scripture say it says Eve told the
serpent God said don't eat it nor what
touch it lest you die she had no reason
not to believe that Eve was quoting what
God told her
until God showed differently do you
follow that
so rather than being a discrepancy it's
simply in the first statement she
basically States what any of the rest of
us would without any further light from
the Lord but remember earlier we talked
about other details
later on her Ministry God gave a vision
and he showed details which said that
those were Eve's words
question
reading the scripture is that possible
from the scripture that those were Eve's
words
how many of you have read the count in
Genesis 3. I've preached that I can't
tell you how many times
and in Genesis 3 it doesn't tell either
you could take it either way
without further light you can read that
and say well you know Eve said then
the Lord said you shouldn't touch it nor
eat it lest you don't don't eat the
fruit nor touch it lest you die
you're assuming well she must have heard
because we don't have a record of God
telling Eve in the Bible do you know
that
Ellen White says that's what we're
talking about Ellen White says that
Ellen that Eve added that Clause to what
God said she added to the words of God
that's all right that's all right
that's the whole point
there's a discrepancy do you see the
discrepancy we're talking about here
in one Passage
in 1864 Ellen White wrote
that
when Eve was begotten by the serpent
to eat of the fruit of the only tree
which God had forbidden them to eat it
or touch it lest they die
she said it was God's word God told them
not to eat it or touch it
in 1864 that's what Ellen White said do
you follow that
okay I'll touch on that in a moment
yeah Eve it says the Lord said listen
Okay let me let me reenact this for you
the Lord said we all need to clear the
building and run over to the church
right now
I said the Lord said
right did he say it
I'll be honest I just made that up
just because Eve says the Lord said does
that mean the Lord said it
I can show you examples in Jeremiah and
other places where the where the false
prophet said thus saith the Lord Lord
capitals Jehovah and then they would
prophesy did Jehovah say it no
and so we have Eve's where he's quoting
there and he says the Lord said to the
serpent the serpent says did God say you
can't eat of any of the tree of the
garden she says well this is what God
told us to do
okay so we can read that in in there and
we can say and that's exactly what Ellen
White said in 1864 well it looks to me
like the Lord told Adam and Eve
not to eat the fruit or touch the fruit
now if you go back in Genesis who did
the Lord tell
he told Adam we have record of God
telling Adam we have the direct words of
God too Adam and he didn't say anything
about touching the fruit did he
said don't eat it that's all he said
if you read it in Genesis 3 are you with
me
however
when you go to Eve Eve says we don't
have record of God telling Eve all we
have is Eve say so Eve said God told us
this
so we're assuming
that's what God told them
we're assuming that Eve is quoting what
she must have heard from God even though
we don't have record of God actually
telling you we just have Eve saying this
is what I heard from God
that's exactly what Ellen White wrote in
1864. however
in 1874 Ellen White tells us those
aren't
God's words Eve added that to what God
Said God said don't eat it but Eve got
in her mind
somehow or the other that we should need
it or touch it
and Ellen White further tells us that
it's because of Eve's misunderstanding
of God's words that the serpent she says
the serpent was sitting there in the
tree touching the fruit and eating it
and he says
first of all he's eating the fruit and
he says well look at me I'm a serpent
and I can talk why do you think I can
talk now because I ate that fruit it
makes you wise and then she says he took
it and placed it in the hands of Eve and
said look you touched it and you're not
dying and Ellen White says because of
Eve's misunderstanding of the words of
God the devil played up on that he
didn't say not to touch it but once she
touched it she said look at that I can
touch it I probably could eat it
okay now that's what Ellen White tells
us the question is
she changed her viewpoint here is she a
false prophet
and the point is simply this
in the first View
Ellen White got let me ask you this can
you see how I could how we could look at
it both ways from the scripture without
any further light you see how we could I
could say well
God told Adam this and so
what Eve's saying is different than what
God told Adam
so she's misquoting
I could get that right from the Bible
with no other source couldn't I or I
could say you know evidently between the
time God told Adam and when he told his
wife Eve and she told the serpent
evidently there'd been more information
that we just don't have until Eve
repeated it right we could have both
both viewpoints from the scripture right
what's the purpose of the gift of
Prophecy what's one of the roles
do you give us enlightenment
they're against the doctrinal
understanding and doctrinal unity
God and light in the mind of the prophet
and said this is how it happened could
have been either way in Ellen White's
earlier vision evidently she didn't have
any detail on the words of Eve but later
on in her experience God gave more
detail and says this is what happened
with Eve it wasn't my words it was the
serp it was her she she added to the
words that I had spoken do you follow
what I'm saying there
if you have questions you can see me
afterwards but the bottom line is there
it is in Ellen White's writings it's a
discrepancy
and to me you know I
again with thought inspiration it just
further on in her experience she got
more details than she had an early
experience
do you understand what I'm saying if you
have questions see me about that later
look at the last one
letter e
sister Davis has just called my
attention to an article printed in the
youth instructor of May 31 1894.
the question asked is did I design to
have this sentence just as it appeared
in the instructor
I am surprised to see it just as it
appears
now notice what it's saying here well
let me read on
I'm surprised to see it just as it
appears quote a meat diet is not the
most wholesome of diets and yet I would
take the position that meat should not
be discarded by everyone
I cannot explain why this appears just
as it does Ellen White's still
commenting since the camp meeting at
Brighton I have absolutely banished meat
from my table it is an understood thing
that whether I am at home or abroad
nothing of this kind is to be used in my
family or come upon my table
I would not desire that the sentence
should be modified I'm sorry I would
desire that the sentence should be
modified by changing the knot
to read this way yet I would not take
the position that meat eating uh that
meat be wholly discarded before by
everyone for instance by those dying of
consumption
now the point is she the knot is in
different places okay Ellen White has
this written down understand what's
taking place here Mary sister Davis is
Marion Davis she was Ellen White's
copyist
this was not a copyist error the copyist
said to the prophet is this what you
meant to say
and Illinois says I'm not sure why it
says it that way
I'd rather have it read this way and it
was already printed
it was already printed is this what you
intended
the manuscript is in her writing LMI
says I'm not sure why it reads that way
I would prefer it to read this way
now I will tell you personally if you
read through this I'm not going to spend
the time at the moment but if you read
through the two variations it could be
read different ways I think Ellen White
worded it in such a way that was clear
to her mind
but it wasn't as clear to the reader so
she clarified it and you see that in the
second passage yet I would not take the
position that meat be wholly discarded
by everyone
in essence you could read that first
sentence kind of both ways
a meat diet is not the most wholesome
yet I would take the position that meat
should not be discarded by everyone now
you can read that two ways not be
discarded by everyone could mean
everyone I don't want you to discard me
or it could be saying meat shouldn't be
discarded by absolutely everyone
which is what she said in the second
statement but she clarified the
statement you follow that the wording
has changed Ellen White changed the
wording she said I didn't intend it to
read that way but that's what she wrote
in her handwriting the point is this
there are errors in things that Ellen
White wrote out
or discrepancies some of them I wouldn't
call errors per se it was like the last
one with Eve there are things that were
written that I think
were expanded later on in her own
understanding
but it still doesn't change
the effect of inspiration anymore
than it did in the scripture with the
scripture authors do you follow that
and that's once again why I would take
the position
I don't I don't have a problem with the
original autographs of scripture having
errors in them
that only makes more clear why Allen
whites have some errors in them and yet
in all of it
none of the errors are such that would
destroy a person's faith in fact they've
had the exact opposite
um effect
you with me
last section here matters of major
substance let's go to the Bible First
now I don't know if you're familiar with
this or not this is kind of a neat
little story in the Bible where the
Prophet actually prophesies something
false and has to go back and correct it
have you read this one
uh both of these are the same we're just
going to read it in second Samuel second
Samuel chapter seven
second Samuel
second Samuel chapter seven
starting in verse one second Samuel 7.
and verse 1 are you with me
okay
now it came to pass when the King was
dwelling in his house and the Lord had
given him rest from all his enemies
around that the king sent said to Nathan
the prophet
see now I dwell in a house of Cedar but
the Ark of God dwells inside tent
curtains
then Nathan said to the king go do all
that is in your heart for the Lord is
with you
but it happened that night that the word
of the Lord came to Nathan saying go and
tell my servant David thus says the Lord
would you build a house for me to dwell
in
for I have not dwelt in a house since
the time I brought the children of
Israel up from Egypt even to this day
but have moved about in a tent and in a
tabernacle wherever I have moved about
with all the children of Israel
have I ever spoken a word to anyone from
the tribes of Israel whom I commanded to
Shepherd My People Israel saying why
have you not built me a house of Cedar
now therefore thus shall you say to my
servant David
thus says the Lord of hosts I took you
from the Sheepfold from following the
Sheep to be a ruler Over My People
Israel and I have been with you wherever
you have gone and have cut off all your
enemies from before you and have made
you a great name like the name of Great
Men Who are on the earth moreover I will
appoint a place for My People Israel and
will plant them that they may dwell in a
place of their own and move no more nor
shall the sons of wickedness oppress
them anymore as previously before since
the time that I commanded judges to be
over My People Israel and have caused
you to rest from all your enemies also
the Lord tells you that he will make you
a house
when your days are fulfilled and you
rest with your fathers I will see I will
set up your seed after you he will come
from your body and I will establish his
kingdom he shall build a house for my
name and I will establish the Throne of
his kingdom forever I will be his father
and he shall be my son if he commits
iniquity I will chasten him with the rod
of man and with the blows of the sons of
men but my Mercy shall not depart from
him as I took it from Saul whom I
removed from before you
and your house and your kingdom shall be
established forever before you your
throne shall be established forever
according to all these words and
according to all this Vision so what
Nathan spoke to David what's the essence
of the story Nathan goes in Wartime is
seized Nathan goes in and David calls
her Nathan prophet and he says you know
God I'm dwelling in this nice house
and God's Temple's a tent
he has a burden to build a temple for
the Lord and Nathan the prophet says go
David go up and do all that your heart
did all the desire of your heart and the
Lord will prosper you in this thing and
Nathan walks out and then the Lord says
Nathan pardon me young man
did I tell you to give David that
message
well Lord I just assumed uh Nathan and
he spells out the whole thing to me he
says this is what you're going to go
back and tell David now
and Nathan the prophet had to go back
and reverse the testimony and say pardon
me King David but you know the prophecy
I told you yesterday and I said the Lord
said thus and so
I take it back
all right
this is a Bible prophet
now people say well Ellen White this
that and the other brothers and sisters
you've got a problem with that Ellen
White you're going to have a problem
with the Bible
the Bible
is given through thought inspiration
and in these cases that we looked at of
minor detail God doesn't necessarily
step in they're discrepancies but if
there's an issue that's a major detail
was this a major detail oh yeah gonna
build a temple yeah
um the Lord corrected the detail didn't
he he sent Nathan back in and said you
need to straighten this out with King
Dave
you follow that
now we see the same thing in the
writings of Ellen White be it few and
far between yet we see the same thing in
Ellen White's writings now I've cited
I've given you some examples here uh the
time to begin the Sabbath Herbert
Douglas on page 157 talks about this
when Seventh-Day Adventists began to
keep the Sabbath and wondered when to
start when do you start keeping the
Sabbath you go from uh evening to
evening what does that mean six o'clock
is evening six o'clock is evening at
midnight when do you start the Sabbath
when does the Sabbath go from and when
does it go too
so the church said well let's get a one
of our men to study this thing out and
give us some information on it so they
appointed Jay and Andrews who studied it
out thoroughly came back and gave him
the scripture evidence and said look
evening begins at sunset
now Joseph Bates one of the founders of
the church
was a sailor
and for sale for Sailors in the Sailor
mindset even at six o'clock world around
six o'clock is evening
Sunset no we're not going to go for that
and of the whole Congregation of the
whole church
that had this viewpoint
the only two dissenters
were Joseph Bates and Ellen White
who said we're not going to keep Sabbath
from Sunset to Sunset
and so the Lord comes to Ellen White and
says
pardon me huh
uh
Elder Andrews was correct
in what he said
and the Sabbath needs to be observed
from Sunset to Sunset
and so the prophet had to go back and
tell the people pardon me
Elder Bates and I were wrong
and this is where God would have us to
stand on this issue
now that's an awesome little story
because it reveals a couple things
number one the air and see the Prophet
The Prophet was not infallible they were
a human being like anybody else they
struggled with sin and temptation just
like anybody else
another thing that it reveals
what's that
oh
another thing that it reveals
is that uh I lost my train of thought
that happens sometimes when you get old
Douglas brought out something let me
look it up on you you can look in at 157
of this book if you have it but it was a
point that he made
what was I thinking oh here it is listen
to this
you know there were people who said that
Ellen White went into Vision just to
have a convenient Vision to help clarify
what she believed and they said that
Ellen White's Visions were only Ellen
White's opinions so that Ellen White
could establish by a quote-unquote
vision the things that she believed in I
mean for example wouldn't it be
convenient that I say uh you know what
the Lord says that uh we had to eat ice
cream Sunday's breakfast lunch and
dinner that's that's saith the Lord you
know or whatever I come up with and uh
so now I have a convenient Vision that
says this is what the Lord says that we
ought to do and they said Ellen Weiss
just coming up with stuff to suit her
own
uh fancy her own way of doing things
okay that was the allegation of some of
the critics
so here's what Uriah Smith says in in
the commenting on this situation with
the beginning of the Sabbath he says
lest any should say that sister White
having changed her sentiments had a
vision accordingly in other words she
had a vision that accorded with her own
opinion
we will state that which was shown her
in Vision concerning the commencement of
the Sabbath was contrary to her own
sentiment at the time the vision was
given
so it reveals to us that if Alan white
has a vision that corrects even her
that's more evidence to you and I it
must be an authentic vision
because even she was corrected by vision
do you follow that
okay so there's a discrepancy the Lord
had to straighten that one out
another one was that southern publishing
Association the work in the South you
know our work in the South began slowly
uh Ellen White's son Edson white was
beginning to work
in the South with the colored people
and what happened is
um
he began a publishing house but the
publishing house was losing money to
tune it to the tune of twelve thousand
dollars a year
that's a lot of money back then
and so they came the Brethren came
together and of course they were kind of
uncomfortable because the talk was L
minus just taking care of her son
her son's running the thing down there
and so she's not going to say anything
about it
and so Ellen White yielded to those
feelings that she had the Brethren
giving her pressure and she looked at it
and they came and they said we're
singing down there we don't have any
money we're going in the hole further
and further and and we don't really see
a need for that publishing house we can
publish it Pacific press we can publish
the review and Harold we don't need that
publishing house down there in the south
southern publishing you know we just
need to fold the whole thing
and so Ellen White in a general
conference meeting said so be it let's
close the Publishing House in the south
and commenting on that this statement
from Spalding began collection 282-284
she says during the night following our
interview in my house and out on the
lawn under the trees October 19 1902.
in regard to the work in the southern
field the Lord instructed me that I had
taken away
wrong position for three nights in
succession I was instructed by the Lord
that I had spoken unadvisedly that
matters had not been correctly
represented to me some of the
particulars not being given so there's a
couple elements there she says you know
I'd spoken wrongly the Lord revealed
number one sister white you've spoken
wrong
you need to go straighten this out
number two she says
you know she based her decision on the
on the on the reports of the Brethren
well
we're not making any money down there
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna spend all our money on this
public she says as the Lord showed her
Envision you did they didn't give you
all the straight facts on this situation
that's what the Lord showed her Envision
that's what he said for three nights she
said uh the matters had not been
correctly represented to me
and because of the pressure and she's
worrying about dude they're saying
you're favoring your son okay go ahead
we'll close it down
but the bottom line is that's that
wasn't what the Lord wanted her to do
and because would that have affected the
work of The Seventh-Day Adventist Church
in a huge way What affected the work in
the south in a huge way and so the Lord
immediately steps in intervenes in that
situation and straightens out the
situation says you go back and you tell
the Brethren that publishing house is
going to stay
which she did
and it ended up turning around and being
a huge source of blessing for our work
in the South you follow that
so those are some things some examples
of
um
some example of of major matters of
substance that the Lord did have to
correct that were errors
through the ministry of the prophet
both in the scripture in the spirit of
Prophecy now one thing that I want you
to capture is everything we talk you may
say boy I don't know some of that makes
me a little uneasy look we've seen it in
the Bible and in the spirit of Prophecy
same mode of inspiration
and it shouldn't shake you in any way
shape or form
number three look at what it says in
number three this does not in any way
affect the inspiration of all scripture
rather it is a part of the inspiration
process I added and reveals the mode of
inspiration employed when we see this
and see the workings of this it helps us
to clarify the fact that yes this is
thought inspiration this is not verbal
inspiration
look at the quote there below by w h
Littlejohn
it says wh Littlejohn president of the
Battle Creek College was asked do sdas
regard Ellen White as infallible
he replied no
neither do they believe that Peter or
Paul was infallible
they believe that the Holy Spirit which
inspired Peter and Paul was infallible
they believe also that Mrs White has
from time to time received Revelations
from the spirit of God and that
Revelations made to her by the spirit of
God are just as reliable as the
Revelations made by the same Spirit to
other persons no problem with the
revelation we understand how the
Revelation the inspiration works
but the prophet herself the prophets
themselves were not infallible people
letter B the prophet as inspired from
God receives Revelations from God in
behalf of the church
the prophet then communicates that
message in his own words and with the
inherent weaknesses of humanity there
are times that mistakes are made however
in the case where the Prophet airs and
that error is serious enough to affect a
the direction of God's church or B the
Eternal Destiny of even one Soul or see
the purity of even one Doctrine
then and only then
the spirit moves in usually immediately
usually through the very same Prophet
who made the error and God then corrects
the errors so that there is no permanent
damage done to the church or its members
you follow that
so the Seventh-day Adventist today
uh SDA has continued today to hold that
that should be egw not wgw that's a type
over a typo rather
Egypt should be typed over it's a typo
uh that Ellen White egw Ellen G Y was
and still is number one reliable
number two trustworthy number three
authoritative possessing all of the same
prophetic Authority invested in every
other prophet of earlier times we'll
touch more on that when we get into
prophetic Authority
number four inspired in the same manner
and to the same degree as were the
prophets who wrote the Bible
letter A yet
we do not make of her writings another
Bible
nor yet an extension or an addition to
the sacred Canon of scripture
and for some last minute
last minute clarification
as soon as I find where I put them I've
got some handouts
who wants to hand them out you got a lot
of handouts today didn't you
who wants to hand these out for me let's
take a few here
yeah let me let me get a couple of you
guys to do it are you volunteering
people
what you are getting
what you are getting here
oh
you may feel okay with that but man I
just feel like I got a shout
he probably sounds like I'm shouting too
but it doesn't sound like it to me
without my ears okay what you are
getting
it says appendix a this is from
incidentally I need to tell you that
there's a number of things a number of
things that I've pulled one of the
resources that I've used besides
Herbert Douglas's book are Roger Coombs
Seminary notes Roger used to be a
I believe the vice president
of the uh or or assistant director of
the white estate
and some of you are familiar with who
Roger Kuhn is but this came from some
materials that he'd put together it
actually is reprinted if you look at the
top
um this is the first draft of this
statement was published in the Adventist
review of July 15 1982.
and in Ministry magazine of August 1982
this revision version revised version
rather appears appeared in the Adventist
review of December 23 1982 in in
Ministry in February 1983. now what was
happening in 1982-1983 what do you think
was the response for
Desmond Ford left the church in 1981
wasn't great
yeah Ford and Ray I'm sorry Ray came on
the heels of Fort
see Ford started out with his degrees of
inspiration and started questioning the
mode of inspiration he didn't believe in
thought inspiration and started to
question that and when he did that a lot
of people just jumped on with that and
said oh yeah uh Ellen White you know
people that believed in verbal
inspiration well and they came up with
all their degrees of inspiration
um
Ford said that he believed that Ellen
White was inspired
just not as inspired as Bible prophets
and because of that that's why she makes
some mistakes here and there Etc that
was his take so in response if you look
at it read the top there that opening uh
paragraph from the biblical Research
Institute in response to requests a
statement on the relationship of the
writings of Ellen G white to the Bible
was prepared initially by an ad hoc
Committee of the general conference
the statement was published in the July
15 Adventist review and August issue of
ministry with an invitation to readers
to respond to it suggestions from
readers and from several groups have led
to a refinement of the statement
to its present form although it is not a
voted statement
we believe that the worldwide
participation in its development makes
it a reflection of the views of the
church on the topic IT addresses and
this is our view today just looking
under the affirmation skipping ahead you
can read through the rest of it later
number one we believe that scripture is
divinely revealed word of God and is
inspired by the Holy Spirit number two
we believe that the Canon of scripture
is composed only of 66 books of the Old
and New Testament number three we
believe that scripture is the foundation
of faith and the final Authority in all
matters of Doctrine and practice
number four we believe that scripture is
the word of God in human language number
five we believe that scripture teaches
that the gift of Prophecy will be
manifest in the Christian church after
New Testament times
number six we believe that the ministry
and writings of Ellen White were a
manifestation of the gift of Prophecy
number seven we believe that Ellen White
was inspired by the Holy Spirit and that
her writings the product of that
inspiration are applicable and
authoritative especially
to Seventh-Day Adventists number eight
we believe that the purposes of the of
the Ellen White writings include
guidance in understanding the teachings
of scripture and application of these
teachings with prophetic urgency to the
spiritual and moral life number nine we
believe that the acceptance of the
prophetic gift of Ellen White is
important to the nurture and unity of
The Seventh-Day Adventist Church number
10 we believe that Ellen White's use of
literary sources which we haven't
covered yet and assistance finds
parallels in some of the writings of the
Bible which we will look at
denials we do not believe that the
quality or degree of inspiration in the
writings of Ellen White is different
from that of scripture
number two we do not believe that the
writings of Ellen White are in addition
to the Canon of sacred scripture number
three we do not believe that the
writings of Ellen White function as the
foundation and final authority of
Christian faith as does Scripture
number four we do not believe that the
writings of Ellen White may be used as
the basis of Doctrine number five we do
not believe that the study of the
writings of Ellen White may be used to
replace the study of the scriptures
number six we do not believe that
scripture can be understood only through
the writings of Ellen White
number seven we do not believe the
writings of Ellen White exhaust the
meanings of scripture number eight we do
not believe that the writings of Ellen
White are essential for the proclamation
of the truths of scripture to the
society at Large
number nine we do not believe that the
writings of Ellen White are the product
of mere Christian piety
in other words she wasn't just a good
Christian woman that wrote We believe
she's a prophet number 10 we do not
believe that Ellen White's use of
literary sources and assistance negates
the inspiration of her writings we
conclude therefore that a correct
understanding of the inspiration and
authority of the writings of Ellen White
will avoid two extreme two extremes
number one regarding these writings as
functioning on a canonical level
identical with scripture
or number two considering them as
ordinary Christian literature
yes sir
yeah
can someone pick that off and say that
she's saying she was less inspired than
Barbara that's what they do that's what
they do question lesser light and
greater light you've heard this before
Ellen White said she was a lesser light
leading to the greater light we're going
to look at this more tomorrow you have
you heard that sure okay
um do you know where that's that phrase
is employed in the Bible
she was just using the words of
scripture the scripture talk about a
lesser light and a greater light
okay uh Ellen White makes reference to
that I'm going to touch on that in a
minute Ellen White also says that John
the Baptist was a lesser light leading
to a greater light did you know that
we're going to see that but in the
scripture the scripture doesn't bring
that phrase up where does the scripture
talk about a lesser light and a greater
light
okay Genesis is talking about what
the sun and the
and the what noon
question does the moon have any light
no
so it's a lesser light the Bible calls
the moon a lesser light why because it
doesn't have any
light of its own where does the moon get
its light
is it of the same quality
as the light of the Sun not quantity
quality
yeah it's the light it's the same light
that's like saying I'm shining a light
in a mirror and you see the light
shining off the mirrors it's the same
quality of light absolutely it's the
same it's a very same light
all you're seeing is a reflection of the
very same light that I'm using right so
the Moon is simply a reflection of the
light of the sun is it the same light as
as is it the same light yes it is is it
in the same intensity
no
when Ellen White said she was a lesser
light
she simply was saying this I'm not the
originator of it
I'm a reflection
I'm a reflection of the True Light and
in that case the light was the light of
the scriptures one author
use the example in that lesser light
greater light idea
it has uh he he compared one candle with
40 candles
okay one candle would be a lesser Light
40 would be a greater light are they
both light
are they both the same kind of light
yeah is one brighter absolutely and
because of the collection
of the writings of the prophets in the
scripture it's a greater light
because it's the test it's a greater
light but that doesn't mean that the
light
of the Prophet is a Different Light than
the light of the scripture doesn't mean
it's less inspired so for a person who
says well that means a different degree
of inspiration number one they're
picking up on what Ellen White says they
need to go back and see what the Bible
says about lesser light and greater
light and make the application
when you understand what the Bible uses
the way the Bible uses lesser light and
greater light
it's very clear that all she's saying is
I didn't originate this stuff I'm a
reflection
and the greater light always of course
is Jesus Christ and the light of the
scripture Ellen White was pointing
people back to the scripture does that
make sense
are there any any other questions
somebody have a question
how do we know
um
that's a good question that's a good
question first of all I'll tell you this
it wasn't
yeah
Ellen White herself says not everything
I've written is inspired
she wrote grocery lists she wrote
letters to people it wasn't inspired oh
look at this we've saved them all you
know no not everything and she said not
everything she wrote was inspired but
I'll tell you this how do we know when
the prophet gave a message and said this
is inspired it's inspired
see we take what we've done is we've
taken a lot of letters and things that
all white has written she didn't write
it as an inspired source for example uh
dear Emma to her I believe Emma was her
daughter-in-law writes her a letter
that's not inspired does it not does it
contain Good Counsel I'm sure it does
because she's going from you know for
example I'm not inspired in the sense
that a prophet's inspired but I may give
you good counsel you call it
inspirational and I'm sure that there
are things we know that there are
letters that Ellen White wrote they're a
letter they're within letters Ellen
White might have wrote written a letter
to Emma dear Emma how are you doing
things are nice here the weather's fine
it's lovely now Emma I have something I
need to talk to you about the Lord has
shown me now you know she clarifies when
you can read write in the writings and
know when she's switched into Council
mode
and I've got we'll we'll touch on this
in more detail
anything that Ellen White has published
as a testimony
the testimonies for the church the
conflict of the ages series etc those
were published with the understanding
for all God's people this is inspired
material
the reality is we've got enough inspired
material that we know is absolutely
inspired from Ellen White uh you know
people get people people try to pull out
uh you know one thing that we do
sometimes is people will try to pull
some statement out and say yeah I know
what Ellen White says most are writings
but did you see this I pulled this out
this came from the vaults or there's
hidden writing somewhere have you heard
that kind of stuff so we were talking
about it the other day there's hidden
writings in the vaults that nobody's
seen there's a secret vault in the white
estate nobody's gotten into it and
there's hidden writings in there that
nobody's seen
give me a break we have thousands of
pages of manuscript from Ellen White and
I I it's the same thing uh that uh Mark
Twain said about the Bible he says not
the things in the Bible that I don't
know but the things that I do know that
cause me sleepless nights
we got plenty of things from Spirit of
Prophecy that we know are inspired that
we can be focusing on but as far as how
to know we'll talk more in detail about
that tomorrow
so and if I don't answer it ask the
question again you say yeah that wasn't
clear yet ask it again Mark you had your
hand up
fired and then many letters to families
you know what I'm saying yeah we'll talk
about that I've had a few questions
about compilations
and we'll talk about that tomorrow uh
other questions
yes did you have a hand up
you're like no no we want to get out of
class we're going to get out of class
all right we'll get out of class
we're on the condition that tomorrow
morning you come bright-eyed and
bushy-tailed you go home now and you get
out of class on time your get your rest
tonight
all that
got the meetings tonight listen let me
tell you something
I went to the meeting the other night
and long after the meeting was gone and
long after the guests were gone
a lot of you guys are hanging out there
you know doing
nobody twisted your arm go home and get
to bed
come here in the morning if you want to
stay up late that's great just come here
Alert in the morning all right
yeah anyway you know
let's bow our heads for a closing prayer
and let me say this
if you have if you do have some
questions that come up anytime on what
we've covered maybe even after class
tonight and stuff jot it down
we'll take some time we will take some
time to answer that you know more than
just what we have here and anytime you
want to come and ask me a question just
one-on-one feel welcome to do it okay
let's bow our heads
Our Father in Heaven well we thank you
Father for for being with us today and
um
helping us father to stay alert and
opening and expanding our minds to to
understand more of the subject that
we've looked at today Father you're the
one that's given this gift
the spiritual gift of Prophecy
and so father I continue to appeal to
you to make that gift clear to us how
the how it worked what its purpose is
continue to make that clear to our
hearts and our minds
father tonight I pray that during the
Evangelistic meeting the hearts would be
touched by the message I pray a special
blessing on the Evangelist tonight that
Lord the word that we would be with
power
and father I pray that each one of us
would learn something tonight we listen
intently and bring home something new
something that we can apply in our lives
something that will draw us closer to
you
and father in all these things we ask
and pray at all in the name of Jesus and
for his sake
amen